he was the hood uh black panther oh yeah
he was the hood black what do you mean
you were
bro [ __ ] the day black panther the day
black panther died [ __ ]
i showed up to my little uh nephew
birthday party dressed as the black
panther
[Laughter]
yeah yeah and they're they're not
bringing them back in the new black
panther
oh yeah right there the left oh [ __ ]
look at this dude
i don't even know them kids
yo i was in england black panther doing
birthday parties in engle
black panther didn't even have a stick
just swinging it was a pinata
bro that's hilarious those kids are
crunk for it though yeah they're here
for it
[Applause]
here's the thing that's not even black
panther's mask
you got some missy elliott glasses and a
cat woman have it batman
you see
i've ever seen
those kids those kids are like daddy
that ain't like manchester united
dude i showed my kid black panther they
would be
[ __ ] terrified yo that nigga's a
freak
this one yeah hold on well look this is
when he died and i was like i heard
y'all looking for a new black pepper
[ __ ]
are like why does he have a bow stack
the boots that's the mask
look at the nose
it's a little cricket is it no it's like
white zoomy
[Music]
i was trying to do the black panther
fist and all that [ __ ]
yeah see you were not even dude if you
try renting a super hero during covet
times it's what you get
this is what you get i got this coveted
spider-man from my son's fourth birthday
party that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] not fun oh [ __ ]
yeah i didn't charge him for that though
how did you get on the roof i mean i
climbed
i climbed up on the side of the house
yeah uh no no that was actually my
auntie house and my cousin put a
[Applause]
me they wasn't like uh first of all
that's a batman man
i said black lantern
little [ __ ] ungrateful
two black panthers would have been dead
but i'm here with y'all
give me some of that cake okay
look really [ __ ] my food
oh
you start taking money back your game
just imagine if kids just got finished
watching black panther are you sure dude
i know right
if you do anything bad and the media
picks it up this would be the first
picture
jamar neighbors also known as black
lance
pictured here basically it is
just in case a game pop off [ __ ]
i bet that was fun as [ __ ] though [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you have a good time
yeah hell yeah he said i think
what's so funny because at that party
that that's actually my little uh
nephew party at that party i didn't take
the mask off no nothing because [ __ ] if
i'm in character
i'm in character now i was really
sitting there [ __ ] eating wings and
[ __ ] with the mask
[Applause]
i'm in movies too [ __ ]
[Applause]
what else have i been doing just stand
up when i can and um
writing how about that when i get off
stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son